the Vegas chamber even brought out the
rainbow ribbon for us to cut to open our
Center we have a ton of services from
social groups support groups we have our
3D printing class after school tutoring
we have our Wellness Clinic with a free
rapid HIV testing STI testing Trevor
harder ecstatic to now be a part of the
north Las Vegas Community as a youth
services director at the North Las Vegas
Equality Center he and other organizers
officially opened their doors Saturday
met by several city and state
representatives from Susie Lee's office
to Dina Titus and Governor Joe Lombardo
as well as the north Las Vegas Police
Department harder stating that opening
up a location in North Las Vegas has
been in the works for a while because
it's obvious that the need is there
transportation is an issue for a lot of
people so bringing it to North Las Vegas
we open up our services to a whole
plethora of people that can't make it to
Henderson for whatever reason from their
food pantry managed by three Square to
their social support groups and wellness
clinic we do see a lot of of patients
coming in and there is you know we're in
southern Nevada we're one of the highest
ranked for new HIV infections it's again
a safe place for them to come get tested
treatment if they need it all of those
things and Dr Christina Madison a
clinical pharmacist here in Clark County
acknowledging the increase she has seen
here locally we've had an increase in
rates of infections here in in the state
of Nevada and then particularly in Clark
County and Southern Nevada the issue
around people having unsafe sex or
having you know sexual encounters
without a barrier method or without use
of prep which is pre-exposure
prophylaxis against HIV is because they
they either don't have a perceived risk
or they feel like if they do get
something there's a treatment for it
quality Center has one doctor on site
who splits their time between North Las
Vegas and Henderson I was told that
their next step is to get Mental Health
Counselors at their facility too in The
Newsroom Addison Kimbrough 8 news now
announced for their hours the north Las
Vegas Equality Center is open Monday
through Thursday 2 P.M to 8 pm